I totally when I'm alone and my kids are  at their dads I totally strut around  naked and I lock all the doors and I  literally like I love it so much there's  a sense of me that thinks this is crazy  you know it's not that I'm even like so  free and comfortable but I still enjoy  it I'm like I'm in a state of being  slightly torn but I'm so excited to have  the opportunity so I totally get it  totally this is this that's why I'm like  why is this news right right right so  would you do the dishes naked too yeah I  think the dishes are a good thing to do  you don't want to cook naked you get  like a splatter a grease the tire on  your body totally fine nipple yeah yeah  you know that's not gonna sudden pasta  night is at the ER